- New SpongeBob still
plays incredibly well.
And then also the spinoffs,
like we're talking,
we have Camp Coral coming up.
We have a Patrick Star spinoff.
We have a Sandy Cheeks spinoff.
So we really are able to
build on that franchise,
because all of the characters are so rich.
(powerful music)
- [Gary] You got your perspective.
(audience cheering)
I just want to be happy.
Don't you want to be happy?
(upbeat bluesy music)
- Before Nickelodeon, she was the CMO
of Gimlet Media, a Spotify company.
She was the head of marketing for Hulu,
and prior to that was the
VP of marketing at Netflix.
We're excited to hear about
Jenny's impressive experiences,
and Jenny, please help my
child stop watching Paw Patrol
all the time around the clock.
Y'all have, you won,
you won in this house,
Paw Patrol's everything over here.
- [Jenny] Thank you,
Paw Patrol, everything.
- Good job.
- Jenny, it's great to see you.
Thank you so much for being
part of this and anchoring us
on this wonderful morning.
- Thank you, Gary, and thank you, Roy.
I'm excited to be here.
- Jenny, I'm actually going
to use your prior experience
a little bit here to bring value,
because I'm reading
Twitter and trying to bring
as much value to everybody.
Hashtag Marketing For the Now if you have
a question or an observation.
Jenny, talk to me about audio.
Obviously, you know, you being at Gimlet,
and a pioneer there, just two seconds
before we go into other matters.
How do you see audio as a, as a medium?
Where do you see it sitting?
Obviously, you know, Roy's
career a lot, you know,
was built on the back of radio.
We see this whole
revolution of podcasting.
Your two cents on it,
because I do think you have
a lot of important observations.
- Yeah, I mean, audio, I
specifically took the job at Gimlet
in order to learn audio,
because I felt like it was
an extremely important
touchpoint that was missed
during the day, from that
I used to call it the,
well I still call it the
idea of the ear strategy,
meaning once they leave the
couch, how do you actually keep
people engaged in your brand?
And with Alexa, and with
cars, it's just makes sense
that you continue the
story throughout audio,
or whether that's in your ears.
And it's also what I learned there is
just how intimate, really,
the audio experience is.
And I, Daniel X said something
really, I think important
when he acquired, or his
company acquired Gimlet,
obviously that just showed
the, I think, relevance
of where they were putting their
bets in regards to Spotify,
embedding in podcasts, and
also just audio storytelling.
And he said, "I can't believe
that the ear or the eye is
ten times more expensive
to buy than the ear."
And he just felt like that
was just something to say
this is actually an
extremely important medium.
And so going to there
has actually helped me
as another step in my
career to realize, okay,
let's just use an
example for Blue's Clues,
and maybe your son's too old for that,
but Blues Clues, we're going to do
Story Time with Josh and
Blue, whereas you could use it
at nap time, or you
could use it at bedtime.
And so just trying to find
these moments or like, okay,
the average drive is eight minutes to,
you know, to a preschool.
What do I do with the kid in the car?
And okay, I've got them
listening to Story Pirates,
because it's actually an audio experience.
And then also I just think that parents,
including myself with a six year old,
especially during this
time, is really trying
to figure out, "How do I
get my kid off the iPad?"
And if I can get them into more
of imagination through sound,
and actually creating worlds,
just through listening.
- I think that's a big deal.
- Yeah, it's so anyway, that
was longer than my two cents
or two seconds, but I
do, I think audio plays-
- No, no, but this is
why we wanted you on,
and this is why I wanted that question.
I think your point, when
you, when you listen to some
of the incredible storytellers
of the 1970s, 1960s,
a lot of them referred to
sitting around the radio
and listening pre-TV
as an incredible driver
for their capacity for imagination.
And I think why not replicate that?
I like that.
Roy?
- When you all, let's
just talk about the pivot
at Nickelodeon, the
cultural pivot, not COVID,
but with George Floyd and
just totally as a company.
What were some of the internal
discussions that you all had
as you started making
the decision over it?
Because I feel like the
corporations and networks,
there was kind of a
staggering of which companies
and which media started doing stuff,
and I felt like Nickelodeon
was at the front of that.
What was, where was the decision?
Talk me through the decision to be one
of the first networks to
make a bold statement.
And you can tell everybody
what the statement was
with the eight forty six.
- Yeah, so it wasn't hard at all.
And that was, I think
we realized very quickly
what side we wanted to be on.
And Viacom, CBS came out
with, we're going to go dark.
Bob came out, we're going to go dark
for eight minutes and 46 seconds.
And we said, "Who is participating?"
And I have to give credit to my boss,
Brian Robbins didn't waste one second
and said, "Every single
network including Nick Jr."
We did want to make a statement
in regards to where our support lies.
We also truly, truly
believe that education
and enlightenment starts
at a very young age,
and that we have the platform
to help start education,
and actually foster those
difficult conversations,
but also help educate and enlighten
is the word that we like to use,
so not just entertained,
but also enlighten.
And so it was a very
simple decision to go dark
for eight minutes and forty six seconds.
And so there was a couple
of different spots.
There was a George Floyd, eight minutes
and forty six seconds of a man breathing,
a very, very provocative that caused a lot
of conversation I will say,
on on Twitter and social
just about how to talk to children.
And we also ran a Kid's Bill
of Rights for eight minutes
and forty six seconds, so "You
have the right to be heard.
You have the right to not be judged
by the color of your skin.
You have the right to an education."
That's turned into a much larger campaign
that we're running, but
that also, so there was,
it was a very easy decision for us.
And, you know, we believe, you
know, all the conversation,
you know, really opened up to say,
"Listen, you know, we can actually talk
to out kids about more difficult things.
And it allowed us to say,
"Listen, we're treating
our children, like, with kid gloves."
And we're also treating
our children, you know,
some people have different experience,
and some kids live in fear every day,
and we owe it to ourselves
for white children,
for black children, to
open this conversation,
because racism starts between
the ages of two and four,
and is embedded by age twelve."
And I think that we have
them in the sweet spot,
two to two to eleven.
And so we cannot not
help in this situation.
And thus, I think then
moving on to the Juneteenth
education that we did on
that Friday, the 19th.
And then moving to Alicia Keys,
we did another town hall
for Race, Kids and Unity.
That again, you could watch
on YouTube if you'd like,
it's really incredible, some
schools have picked it up
to sort of teach and help
start the conversation,
but it was not hard for us at all.
And we're continuing to,
you know, I've now made this
an initiative at
Nickelodeon where, you know,
we're putting money behind it,
and I'm working with Maverick
Carter, LeBron's company,
and we're hopefully working with them.
We're coming up with ways
we could work together
to develop content, whether
short form, long form,
that this is not just a campaign.
It's a sustained effort
that we continue to do,
both inside the company
and outside the company,
meaning diversify our employees
also, as well as our vendors
and our outside, behind the
camera, in front of the camera.
It's become a huge initiative for us,
and we are definitely not slowing down.
- What's the biggest
challenge for, you know,
you and your executive
team during COVID itself.
When it first hit, were you surprised
by any of the remote capabilities,
or did you feel like that
was going to work out?
You have obviously worked
in some progressive companies in the past.
Did you yourself, are you missing like,
random interactions in
the office and travel,
or are you loving this?
Like, little bit of just like the insights
to leaders during this time.
- I think it's incredible how people have
creatively pivoted and
sort of embraced and solved
a lot of the creative
adaptability if you will.
So, yes, I think we all miss a little bit
of those hallway conversations,
and we miss being able to,
you know, basically just knock on,
walk in and talk to somebody.
But I think what's been really great is
we've been able to figure
out how to do our work,
even if it comes down to shoots,
like, working with families
to shoot themselves.
And I think what we've,
you know, I think Gary,
you and I talked a little
bit about this as sort of,
you know, the humanistic approach.
With the stuff we're doing
now is a lot less polished,
and actually it's working better for us,
because it's more human and it's more
about actually families and
them interacting together.
So I think that's been a really positive.
I'll say the hardest thing
for us is that not being
in production with new
shows, so we're coming up,
we're not able to go on set.
So I think just keeping
the content live alive,
meaning that we're coming up
with shows like Unfiltered,
which is sort of a game show
that we do completely remotely.
We have these Danger Force shorts
we're doing completely remote.
Our marketing team is
now developing shows.
We developed a SpongeBob
Fan Favorite Special
with the cast rereading.
You should go check it
out, it's really fun.
They're, it's on YouTube,
but they're acting out
famous scenes, and it's really great.
So we're just coming up
with kind of creative ideas
of what programming could
be, because this might last
for a really long time.
Animation, obviously-
- How long-
Yeah, animation's in a better spot
than live action or filming.
Do you feel like this is,
like, what's your personal,
like, any insights to that?
I mean, are we looking
at, I mean, at this point,
it feels like the rest of
this year is definitely not
going to be the normal
we knew prior to this.
Is there programming concerns?
Or because I was going to just ask that,
your animation shops, do
you feel like you're sitting
in a little bit of a better spot
than maybe some of your contemporaries?
- I think we are sitting,
I mean, animation takes
a really long time to do,
so we're having to speed up
that process a little bit,
but it's really great.
We have some amazing
shows, like Casa Grandes,
The Loud House, we have New SpongeBob,
we have It's Pony we just renewed.
We have also just, you
know, green lit a bunch
of other things that will
happen come next summer.
So we're, I think we're in
a very good place there.
And I think we're also
in a very good place
that we've got an incredible
YouTube team that comes
from Fullscreen run by Ashley Kaplan,
that actually can make incredible content
remotely really well.
So I think we're in a really good spot,
but I would say that for
the rest of this year,
it is going to be challenging, you know,
especially with what's
happening in California
how it seems to be getting
worse at the moment.
But we're cautiously
optimistic that we'll get
a few things in, and
we're shooting some things
in Vancouver, which is in a better space.
So I think we're definitely
going to have a good Q4.
And so that's, that's the thing.
I think some people
that are able to shoot,
let's say, in Europe,
might be at a better place,
but if you can shoot in Canada-
- Right, right, right,
right, right, right,
that makes a lot of sense.
Roy?
- As a parent, how much does that,
how much does it help you at your job?
- Oh, immensely.
Another reason I say I take
each job I take for a reason,
when I took audio, I
wanted to learn audio.
I took this job, one,
because I wanted to see if-
well, one, I love Brian Robbins.
I think he's an incredible leader,
and I always wanted to work for him.
And I also just felt
being six years, sort of
on the digital side, what could I bring
to a linear channel that's
evolving into digital
to help it make that move?
But it's also, I would be
lying if I said it doesn't,
I can't, I love it that I'm a hero at my,
that my six year old kid loves what I do,
and also loves the stuff I work on.
But I also have a focus group of one here
that I can bounce things off him,
and I run trailers behind him and say,
you know, in front of him,
and so it's really incredible.
And also it's really
helped to open dialogue.
You know, the thing we
were talking about before
with George Florida and racism
about how I talk to my child.
And it's helped figure
out, like, how do I talk
to a kindergartner about
racism, and he's going to be
in first grade, and how do I
talk to like, a sixth grader?
And it's very different.
And so we're finding
these ways to figure out,
"How do I make the most
impact with each age?"
And so I do have one
focus group of one here
that's six that I can
bounce some things off of.
- Really important question for me,
can you please go to
some sort of warehouse
and steal some rare Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtle stuff
for me so I can flip it on eBay?
Does that, can we, can we make that trade?
Is that allowed?
- No comment on this (indistinct).
We have some new Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtle stuff
coming up, which I'm super excited about.
- Is it, you know, one
thing I'm very fascinated.
I just heard New
SpongeBob, New TMT, right?
Like it's kind of intriguing.
Just give a little glimpse
into this that I think
a lot of viewers wouldn't think about,
which is the incredible opportunity that
once a franchise does hit that status,
it really does play "in perpetuity."
Like, you actually get
to reboot, restructure,
think about, spin off.
It is a real gift to be able to play
with these kinds of franchises.
It's also probably a huge responsibility.
I'm sure there's a lot of
emotion and politics behind it,
but it is fascinating.
I mean, just when I
heard you say, you know,
some New SpongeBob, I'm like, "Ooh!"
You know, TMT, "Ooh!"
Like, it's powerful to
have these franchises.
Thoughts?
- Extremely powerful for us.
And just also, we have
the whole CP side of this.
So we know that, you know,
that from a plush perspective,
like Blues Clues right now is
the number one toy in Walmart,
even during this period of time.
I think people are
looking for some comfort.
But we have that whole
side of where it actually,
we can actually touch lives in a bunch
of different areas when we
create these franchises.
But like SpongeBob, yes,
New SpongeBob still plays
incredibly well.
And then also the spinoffs,
like we're talking,
we have Camp Coral coming up.
We have Patrick Star spinoff.
We have a Sandy Cheeks spinoff.
So we really are able to
build on that franchise,
because all of the characters are so rich.
And then working on the Broadway play
that we aired, also the SpongeBob Musical,
if you haven't seen that, it is so fun,
but it really takes it
into a different realm.
But also just as the same-
- I thought that was super, I saw it,
it was super clever.
Like, that was a challenge.
- Oh, a huge challenge.
- When I first heard it, I'm like, "Ooh."
I thought it was extremely well done.
Not, by the way, not "ooh" like
I don't, like I was pumped.
I was like, "Ooh."
I'm an operator, so I'm like,
"Ooh, how the hell would I operate that?
Like, where are you going
creatively with that?"
I thought it was super clever where they-
- I think the biggest
thing that was hard is
that SpongeBob doesn't know people exist.
So he doesn't really understand the world.
(laughing)
And so then you've got people
playing SpongeBob and Patrick.
And so there's that little suspension
of disbelief you have to create.
And those characters have to really embody
those characters under
the sea in Bikini Bottom,
and they did an incredible job.
- Jenny, you did an incredible job here.
Thank you for your time.
Hope you have a great,
great rest of the week,
and thank you for your leadership
in marketing community.
- Thank you so much, and
thanks for having me.
It was good to see all of you.
(smooch) Bye bye.
(whimsical music)
Hey, everybody on YouTube.
First of all, thank you so much.
So humbled for your time.
I don't wear a watch, but
time is the biggest asset.
So thank you for watching that video.
If you got some value out of that,
there's plenty more where that came from.
Feel free to check it out.